eux c'est avait vu les conditions météo
nous avons lu surtout de très belles
courses de belles confrontations
donnez donc vu à des empoignades assez
intense il ya enfin du pont champlain
série attendent la dernière manche
d'aujourd'hui pour les départager les
invités niveau de l'inviter je pense que
très satisfaisant parce que notamment à
laser radial il y a eu quand même
de bonnes conditions et il y avait une
opposition entre les suisses et
représentant antigua et la martinique et
ça a été relativement chaud et donc
c'est intéressant pour nous de voir un
petit peu le comportement des
martiniquais dans ce contexte c'est très
bien
laser radial c'était le cas un peu près
cette mesure on a vu alors compliqué à
prendre la tête rapidement et ne pas la
lâcher
il n'est par contre derrière on voit la
chine que l'europe qui remonte
très très fort et là je vais pas de
résultats lors des dernières manches
parce que ça va jouer aussi pour la
place sur le podium avec les grands oui
ça fait le succès est bien garantie dans
la mesure où en avant de bonnes
conditions nous avons une équipe
d'encadrement efficace avec des aussi
bien l'équipe technique sur locataires
je pense que les invités vont repartir
les deux bons souvenirs et surtout avec
rétention ils nous ont déjà manifesté à
plusieurs reprises de revenir l'an
prochain pour la frontière entre ce que
nous attendons et malades le contrat
sera lente et s'ils regardent